so we've been speaking about this
boundary between bits and atoms so let
me ask you one of the about one of the
big mysteries of consciousness
do you think
it comes from somewhere between that
boundary I won't name names but if you
know who I'm talking about it's probably
clear I once did a drive in fact up up
to the mussoline era Villa outside
Torino
in the early days of what became Quantum
computing
with
a a a famous person who thinks about
quantum mechanics and Consciousness and
we had the most infuriating conversation
that went roughly along the lines of
Consciousness is weird
quantum mechanics is weird therefore
quantum mechanics explains Consciousness
that was rough roughly The Logical
process
and you're not as satisfied with that
process no and I say that very precisely
in the following sense uh I was a
program manager somewhat by accident in
a DARPA program
on Quantum biology
and so biology
trivially uses quantum mechanics that
were made out of atoms but the
distinction is
in Quantum Computing Quantum information
you need Quantum coherence
and there's a lot of muddled thinking
about like
collapse of the wave function and claims
of quantum Computing that garbles just
Quantum coherence that
um that you can think of it as a wave
that has very special properties but
these wave-like properties and so
there's a small set of places where
biology uses quantum mechanics in that
deeper sense one is how light is
converted to energy in photosystems
it looks like one is olfaction how your
nose is able to tell different smells
um probably one has to do with how birds
navigate
um how they sense magnetic fields
that involves a coupling between a very
weak energy with a magnetic field
coupling into chemical reactions and
there's a beautiful system it
standard in chemistry is magnetic fields
like this can influence chemistry but
there are biological circuits that are
carefully balanced with two Pathways
that become unbalanced with magnetic
fields so each of these areas are
expensive for biology it has to consume
resources to use quantum mechanics in
this way
so again those are places where we know
there's quantum mechanics in biology in
cognition there's just no evidence
there's
uh there's no evidence of anything
quantum mechanical going on in how
cognition Works Consciousness well I'm
saying I'm saying cognition I'm not
saying Consciousness but to get from
cognition to consciousness
so McCullough and Pitts made a model of
neurons
um that led to perceptrons
that then through a couple boom busts
led to deep learning one of the
interesting things about that sequence
is it diverged off so deep neural
networks used in machine learning
diverged from trying to understand how
the brain works
um what what makes them work what's
emerged is they it's a really
interesting story this may be too much
of a technical detail but it has to do
with function approximation that that uh
we talked about exponentials a deep
Network
needs and exponentially larger shallow
Network to do the same function
and that that exponential is what gives
the power to deep Networks but what's
interesting is the sort of lessons about
building these deep architectures and
how to train them
have really interesting Echoes to how
brains work
and there's an interesting conversation
that's sort of coming back of
neuroscientists looking over the
shoulder of people training these deep
networks seeing interesting Echoes for
how the brain works
interesting parallels with it and so I I
didn't say Consciousness I just said
cognition but
that I don't know any experimental
evidence that points to anything in
neurobiology that says we need quantum
mechanics
and
um I view the question about whether a
large language model is conscious as
silly in in that
biology is full of hacks
and it works
there's no evidence we have that there's
anything deeper going on than just this
sort of stacking up of hacks in the
brain and somehow Consciousness is one
of the hacks or an emergent property of
the hex absolutely and um just
numerically I said big computations now
have the degrees of freedom of the brain
and they're showing a lot of the
phenomenology of what we think as
properties of what a brain can do
um
and I don't see any reason to invoke
anything else that makes you wonder what
kind of beautiful stuff digital
fabrication will create if biology
created a few hacks on top of which
Consciousness and cognition some of the
things we love about human beings was
created it makes you wonder what kind of
Beauty in the complexity
there's there's an early peek at that
which is
um there's a misleading term which is
generative design
generative design is where you don't
tell a computer how to design something
you tell the computer what you want it
to do that doesn't work that only works
in limited subdomains you can't do
really complex functionality that way
the one place that's matured though is
topology optimization for structure so
let's say you wanted to make a bicycle
or a table
um you describe the loads on it and it
figures out how to design it and what it
makes are beautiful organic looking
things these are things that look like
they grew in a forest and
they look like they grew in a forest
because that's sort of exactly what they
are that they're they're they're they're
solving the ways of how you handle loads
in the same way biology does and so you
get things that look like trees and
shells and all of that and so that's a
peek at this transition to
um from we we design to to we teach the
machines how to design